ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนอีก
แล้วนะคะในวีดีโออาระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ในวีดีโอระดับดินเนอร์ค่ะบีกินเนอร์ฮา
นอคก็บีกินเนอร์ Class ใช่ไหมคะเราก็ต้อง
มีวันที่ค่าน้องแล้ววันนี้วันอะไรวันที่
เท่าไหร่เดือนอะไรปีอะไรโอเควันนี้วัน
อะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะอ่าวันพฤหัสบดีที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพฤหัสที่ 24 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพปีพ.ศ.ปี
พ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันนี้
พุธค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 23
ค่ะเดือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตอีพต
2565 ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้
วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 25 เดือนเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์
ปีพต
ปี
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
13:00 น
บ่ายโมงกี่นาทีคะ 27 นาทีค่ะ
1:27 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
เป็นเวลากลางวันเป็นเวลากลางวันนะคะแล้ว
เป็นเวลากลางวันไหมอยากให้เล่นอยู่คือ
อะไรให้หรอกประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยเป็นเวลา
เช้านักเรียนบอกประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ย
7:00 นมาเป็นเวลาเช้าเพิ่งตื่นนอนหรือ
โอเคค่ะนั้นรักแต่ว่าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้านะ
คะเป็นเวลากลางวันเนาะกินข้าวเสร็จแล้ว
เต็มอิ่มอิ่มหน้าเล่
[เพลง]
ว่า
เป็นนักเรียนอาจจะแบบอะไรคำได้ไหมเดี๋ยว
ครูหญิงมีรูปให้ดูนะเอารูปแรกณโรงแรก
นี่ค่ะ
รูปแรกนะคะอ่ะรูปนี้นักเรียนเห็นผู้หญิง
คนนี้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ลิ้นอันนี้เป็นลิ้น
ของเขาใช่มั้ยผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยเขาห่อ
ลิ้นในรูปเนี่ยเขากำลังห่อลิ้นแบบนี้นะคะ
ครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะทำได้ก็คือครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าห่อลิ้นได้สมัยถ้าทำไม่ได้ก็คือฟ้า
แบบอ่าขอลิ้นไม่ได้นะครูฟ้าขอลิ้นอยู่ไหน
เนี่ย
อย่าคอลิ้นนะคะแบบนี้แล้วห่อลิ้นแบบนี้
ครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะอ่ะโป้นักเรียนคิดว่าถูก
ขวาทำได้ไหมคะนักเรียนคิดคิดรีบ 1
3  3  4
4  5
จุดทำได้ไหมทำได้หรือเปล่าจะทำให้ภาษาสาว
ๆร้องช้าๆบีกินเนอร์
อะไรนะ
มั้ยกินได้ไหมคะขอลิ้นถูกป่า
ทำได้
รักห่อลิ้นนะคะ
เหมือนแล้วนักเรียนดู
เป็นครูฟ้าชำได้ทำได้
เมื่อฉันง่ายค่ะ Easy ต้องโอ๋
[เพลง]
อย่าบอกนะคะโอเคอ่าอ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
อันนี้เนี่ยนะคะก็คือ
ยักคิ้วข้างเดียวสมัยถ้านักเรียนดูผู้
หญิงเนี่ยก็มีคิวนะ 1  2 แต่คิ้วข้างนี้
แหละเขาอย่าขึ้นใช่ไหมขึ้นแต่อีกข้างนึง
เนี่ยไม่อันนี้เราเรียกว่ายักคิ้วข้าง
เดียวนะคะครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าคำได้ไหมเนาะ 1
2  3  4  5
ครูฟ้าต้องเปิดหน้าผากอ่ะลูกสาวต้องเอาผม
ขึ้นมีฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะรูปฝานะคะตก
แต่
ละห้องอ่างด้วยนะไม่ใช่เปิดใช้กำลังจะบอก
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยยักคิ้วข้างเดียวได้แล้วก็
ยักษ์แบบซ้ายซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวา
โอ่ง
ตัวนะมาใกล้ๆกับผู้หญิงอย่างนี้มาใกล้ๆ
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเนี่ยคุณแน่นะคะอ่ะขอเล่นได้
ยักคิ้วข้างเดียวได้
ผู้หญิงทำได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยนะคะคำ
อวย does  So
ผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้นะไม่ได้นักเรียนทำได้ไหม
นะฮะก็ก็ทำได้ก็ทำแล้วทำไม่ได้ก็เหมือน
ผู้หญิงนะก็ทำได้ก็ทำมาต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้านะ
คะรูปนี้ก็คือเอาลิ้นเอาลิ้นเนี่ยนะคะ
ลิ้นลิ้นหนอนแล้วก็แตะข้อสอบหาข้อสอบอัน
นี้คือข้อสอบของเราเนาะตรงนี้นะคะเอาลิ้น
แตะข้อสอบ
และข้อสอบครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม
นัดเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม 1
3  4  5 ครั้ง
ลูกค้าทำได้ไหมคะยกข้อสอบขึ้นมาฮะแล้วก็
เอาลิ้นไปแตะ
ไม่ได้ผู้หญิง
ฟ้าทำไม่ได้ยากเนาะยากร้อง rov มา
ผู้หญิงในรูปนี้ผู้หญิงในรูปนี้ก็ทำไม่
ได้นะคะทำไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงทำได้ไหมคุยหญิงอ่ะคะผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยยักคิ้วก็ไม่ได้ห่อลิ้นก็ไม่
ได้
เฮ้ยอย่าร้อนไม่ได้นึกว่าได้ไปได้เลยนะ
ทำไมได้
ผู้หญิงก็ทำไม่ได้เนาะ
เรียนทำได้ไหมทำได้มาลองดูข้อต่อไปค่ะก็
ยังอยู่ที่ลิ้นนะแต่ว่าไม่ได้เอาลิ้นแตะ
ข้อสอบนะคะอันนี้เนี่ย
ผู้หญิงคนนี้แหละเขาเอาลิ้นนะเขาพยายาม
เอาลิ้นแตะจมูกลิ้นเมื่อแตะจมูกหมอนิศา
รัตน์ก็แตกจมูก
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมนะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเอาลิ้นแตะจมูกได้ไหม
3  3  4  4  5  5 ค่ะ
เอาลิ้นแตะจมูกเหรอคะสายค่ะเอาลิ้นแล้วก็
แตะจมูก
จมูกนี่ล่ะไม่ได้จมูกอะโทษก็ไม่ใช่จมูก
เสือ
สมุทร
แต่ว่าจมูกครูฟ้าเหรอดูแล้วเรียนค่ะ
หนูฟ้าทองไม่ได้
ไวงานใช่มั้ยผู้หญิงคนนี้ในรูปก็ทำไม่ได้
นะเขาทำไม่ได้ก็เอาลิ้นแต่จมูกไม่ได้นะ
เมื่อยปากว่า
ครูหญิงทำได้ไหมคะลิ้นค่ะจมูก
คุณ
ครูหญิงก็ทำไม่ได้แต่คิดว่าถ้านักเรียน
สมัยนักเรียนเนี่ยอ่ะโป้ฝรั่งไรนักเรียน
เนี่ยเป็นฝรั่ง
ฝรั่งเนี่ยจมูกโด่งใช่ไหมคะ
สมุงเนี่ยโด่งถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยจมูกโด่ง
ออกมาแบบนี้ไงเนี่ยจะเอาลิ้นนะลิ้นแล้วก็
ไม่ได้อาจจะเอาลิ้นแตะจมูกได้ก็ได้นะเรา
เนี่ยจมูกเล็กๆอาจจะไม่ได้เนาะไม่รู้นะคะ
นักเรียนบอกได้นะต้องครูสาเอาลิ้นแตะจมูก
ไม่ได้ใช่ไหมแล้วครูฟ้าอ่ะเอาลิ้นแตะช้าง
สมัยคางเดี๋ยวอีกว่าลูกให้ดูก็ได้ค่ะ
อาจารย์
ค่ะ
วันนี้ลินนะเห็นของเราแล้วก็เอาลิ้นเนี่ย
ลิ้นแตกทางนักเขียนเนาะดูยังอ่ะ
อาแปะค้างโรงฟ้า
ทำได้ไหม
ตานักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าคำได้ไหมนะคะ 1
223  345
ครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะเอาลิ้นแตะคาง
ลิ้นแตะค้างห่า
ไม่ส่งไม่ได้รู้ป๊าทำไม่ได้นะเอาลิ้นแตะ
คางไม่ได้
ใช้มือด้วย
ลิ้นแตะข้างให้เรียนไม่ได้ๆ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่ได้นะผ้วนถ้าแตะจมูกไม่ได้
แตะข้างก็น่าจะไม่ได้นะอ่ะ
แต่ก็ไม่ได้กัน
เรียนทำได้ไหมทำได้หรือเปล่าบอกเราได้นะ
โรงเรียนถ่ายรูปส่งมาให้ครูได้ไหม
นะคะที่อีเมล์อีเมล์ของเรา
ทำยังไงมากข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อต่อไป
อันนี้ค่ะอันนี้ไม่ได้อยู่ที่ลิ้นไม่ได้
อยู่ที่คิ้วไม่ได้อยู่ที่จมูกไม่ได้อยู่
ที่คางแล้วอยู่ที่มือนะคะก็คือ
ก็คือครูฟ้าใช่ไหมสมมติว่าอันนี้เป็นเป็น
อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะผู้ฟ้าเนี่ยเอามือวางที่
นี่นอกวางนะน่าสนปีกันทองเอาไปวางอย่าง
นี้นะคะแล้วก็นิ้วกลางนะคนนี้เนี่ยมันจะ
มีนิ้วโป้งนิ้วชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้วนางแล้วก็
นิ้วก้อย
แบบนี้แต่ก็เอานิ้วกลางเนี่ยพับเข้าไปนะ
คะเพราะว่าตัวนี้นะคะแล้วก็นิ้วโป้งต้อง
ติดที่นิ้วชี้ติดนิ้วนิ้วก้อยติดได้ผู้
ฟ้าเนี่ยยกยกนิ้วนางอาเดี๋ยวนะนิ้วเดียว
นิ้วนางเท่านั้นที่ยกนิ้วก้อยนิ้วชี้นิ้ว
โป้งเนี่ยต้องติดแล้วก็ยกนิ้วนางนะนิ้ว
เดียวครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะยกนิ้วนางนะทุก
อารมณ์ติดนี้ช่วยแล้วก็ยกนิ้วนางนิ้ว
เดียวได้ไหมนะคะหนึ่งสอง
สามสี่
ห้าครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม
ค่ะเอาๆๆนะเจ้า
เอาทำยังไงอ่ะจะเอาอะไรมาลองก็ได้เอ่อให้
กูป่าวแบบไปข้างหลังไว้แล้วผู้หญิงทั้ง
หลานได้ใช่ไหมเราจะเยอะได้ค่ะ
ยกนิ้วนางนิ้วนางนะกูก็ต้องยกนิ้วนางเอา
นิ้วนางขึ้นมานิ้วเดียว
ก็เกือบก็ได้
Visit นะคุณ
[เพลง]
ไม่โอเคคุณต้องเป็นไม่ใช่คนนะกูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงทำได้เลยครับก็ลองให้ดูนะคะพี่แปะ
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ 1 ออนี่มันนั่นก็
ไผ่แล้วก็งอนิ้วกลางใช่ไหมแล้วก็ยกอยู่
ทางไม่ได้เอา
ตัวอย่างทำไม่ได้ผู้หญิงทำไมเพลงทำไมมี
อะไร
นักเรียนทำได้ไหมทำได้ไหวอ่ะสุดท้ายค่ะ
ครูฟ้าโอเค
ก็คือแบบนี้เนาะแต่ก็คือกูฟ้าสามารถมี
นิ้วใช่ไหมนิ้วโป้งนิ้วชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้ว
นางนิ้วก้อยก็คือเอานิ้วนางไปอยู่กับนิ้ว
ก้อยนิ้วกลางมาอยู่กับนิ้วชี้อย่างนี้ใช่
ไหมครูฟ้าทำแบบนี้นะครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมนะนัก
เรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าอ่ะทำได้ไหม
เก่ง
3 ค่ะอือ
ม 5 ครูฟ้ายกมือขึ้นมาค่ะแล้วก็
อ้ะแยกนิ้วนางกับนิ้วกลางนิ้วนางต้องติด
กับนิ้วก้อย
แล้วก็เอานิ้วกลางติดกับนิ้วชี้
1  2 ซ่ำงง
ทำได้นะข้างเดียวก็โอเคนะสมมตินักเรียน
ได้ 1  1 ข้างก็ ok แล้วสองข้าง 2 ข้าง
แบบตัวนี้ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงวันนี้เขาทำได้ 2
ข้างนะข้างซ้ายข้างขวา
ผู้หญิงท้องได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงข้างๆนี้ดีกว่าครั้งนี้ทางนี้ไม่
ค่อยได้
คุยก็
[เพลง]
ต้องได้นักเรียนทำได้ไหมนะคะเพราะว่า
อันแรกใช่ไหมขอลิ้นเนี่ยครูฟ้าทำได้ไหม
ทำปลายทางได้ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้อาหาร
ยักคิ้วข้างเดียวน้องครูฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะทำ
ได้ค่ะครูหญิงทำไม่ได้
เอาลิ้นแตะข้อสอบสมัยแต่ข้อสอบครูฟ้ารู
หญิงทำไม่ได้น่าได้อ้ะเอาลิ้นแตะจมูกหา
แต่สระหมู่เกาลิ้นครูฝากับครูหญิงทำไม่
ได้เอาลิ้นแตะค้าง
ห่าอยู่เหมาะกับผู้หญิงทำไมบัตรไป
ยกนิ้วนางจะมายกนิ้วนางนิ้วเดียวนะครูฟ้า
ทำได้ครูหญิงทำไม่ได้นะคะแต่กูซ่าก็ต้อง
รอต้องนอนนิ้วนิ้วกลางด้วยหลัง
แล้วได้แล้วก็แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะแยกนิ้วกลาง
กับนิ้วนางนะคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยเราสองคนแต่พิมพ์ไม่ค่อยสวยนะ
คะเนี้ยทำได้วิ่งได้ครั้งนี้และกันช่าง
เดียว
ทำได้ลากนักเรียนทำอะไรได้น้องก็เขาไม่
เหมาะเราก็ได้นะว่าข้อไหนนักเรียนทำได้มา
หาวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะเมื่อ
กี้